2020 Democratic frontrunner Joe Biden
reportedly feeling burned by his former
boss according to Vanity Fair the former
VP is upset of a Barack Obama meeting
with other potential twenty20 contenders
like beta O'Rourke before he's
officially made his decision a Biden
spokesperson pushing back against a
story calling it unequivocally false
Biden may have some other obstacles in
his way a new poll showing 59% of
democratic and independent voters are
excited for someone entirely new to run
for president biden comes in second
followed by Bernie Sanders in beta or
orc and 70 percent of those same voters
say Hillary Clinton should not run again
President Trump going after Democrats as
we have more of that no we don't is that
just a poll okay well the teleprompter
is working very well today
mari Harvick I don't think even if Biden
were upset I don't think he would say so
because it's just obvious that Obama is
going to have to meet with lots of
Democrats right into 2020 right yes and
I actually don't think I mean Joe Biden
is an adult right he's been in politics
a long time he and Barack Obama are very
close I don't think he is probably very
upset about this it's interesting though
in that poll 59% want someone new I
think that we see that in both parties
right that's how we got Donald Trump but
Joe Biden was at 53% so Joe Biden knows
that he is very popular in the party
he's popular among independents and
Barack Obama is going to have to meet
with lots of people I do think you will
see President Obama trying to keep his
powder dry a little bit and not really
wait into what will be what 25 30 people
in a Democratic primary here but if Joe
Biden wants to run Joe Biden will have a
lot of support among people like Barack
Obama even if he doesn't endorse him he
was his vice president for eight years I
don't think he's mad about bado getting
a meeting lately he's a thicker skin
than that but he was his vice president
the last election as well and we know
that the party leadership as well as the
president all did the garden meetings
and that you know he wasn't going to run
and this was all because Hillary Clinton
was the chosen candidate and so I do
think that there is he will be
frustrated if the president doesn't get
behind him of course he's
policy understands that the president
he's a former president has to meet with
all the candidates yeah but the per the
former vice president is going to be
expecting President Obama to get behind
it because he did step aside and let
Hillary Clinton it's not easy to tell
somebody that maybe it's not it's past
their time right it's not easy to tell
we're not elephants it's you know you
see the word cult a person or the phrase
cult of personality about the
Republicans that the Republican Party is
now a cult of personality and it's all
about Donald Trump I think it is that is
not true the cult of personality is the
Democrat Party the cult is Donald Trump
but they're an anti Trump party and
that's all they are at this point that's
why they need a new personnel they're
desperately in search of a personality
because they think that Trump is all
about personalities not it's really
about policy they liked his policies not
as personal they didn't want just
someone new Murray they wanted Donald
Trump it wasn't anyone new and so they
are searching for that's why baito is
such a big thing because they're not
really sure about you know why they like
him but they think he's a personality
that can take on Trump that's all they
want they want something they just want
someone who's got a little spark Morgan
maybe you know I'm really looking
forward to this primary because of
someone who was in the Republican
primary it was vicious and awful and
this looks like the Republican primary
times like a thousand like just get out
the popcorn I can't wait what's ironic
to me is how the DIMM activist base is
sort of freaking out that the top three
people in polling are all white men
we've seen a lot of people that have a
problem with that and the Republican
Party has been criticized non-stop by
Democrats are being the party of white
men at any time you opposed a policy a
president brocco Obama must have been
because you're a racist and now the
women and the minorities that are going
to be running for president are gonna be
turning that around on their fellow
Democrats it will be interesting for me
to see how Bernie how Biden how a work
answer that white male charge which is
like almost worse than being a criminal
and the Democrat Party I think what's
interesting is a lot what frustrates me
about fellow Democrats is they're
looking for a savior right now like
they're looking and that's why they look
at bado cuz they just want someone who's
the perfect candidate and a perfect time
I had one in Barack Obama's exact anyone
twice overwhelmingly in one states like
Indiana right
Democrats need to compete in but I keep
telling my fellow Democrats we don't
need a Savior the primary process
sometimes works itself out it sometimes
puts forward a candidate that can win in
general the Republican primary was
insane it put forward the candidate that
could win in a general election same
with Barack Obama in 2008
sometimes these processes actually work
they where people you love them question
the freeze
tell me this about like logistically how
you think things will change when
California moves earlier for their
primary because there's so many
delegates then does that change a lot
that will change it also the fact that
super-delegates these party elders who
were given a lot of power and previous
Democratic primary nominating processes
they helped monoid Hillary Clinton for
example they have much less power now so
the powers been pushed down to the
grassroots activists Democrats in Iowa
are different than Democrats in New
Hampshire and South Carolina Nevada now
no longer a caucus now a primary these
things seem very wonky but they actually
matter when there's going to be a very
hotly contested primary that's why
you're gonna see candidates go to Iowa
go to New Hampshire you already are they
this primary is starting like now the
generational struggle in the Democrat
Party is sort of a fascinating one as
well because the demand a presidential
election you they rely so much on those
younger voters that didn't show out for
Hillary Clinton especially younger women
and the generational struggle just
doesn't about their 20/20 nominee it's
look at the angst that was geared
towards Pelosi and to Schumer people who
are in their 70s and have been in
leadership for a long time and I think
you're sort of seeing the base of the
Democrat Party especially the young
people say you know it's our turn to
lead it's our time for leadership well
one part of the Democrats problem
they're gonna have is that authentic
leadership because there's a lot of
candidates that weren't as far left when
they were in other offices when a county
voted for legislation to essentially
dismantle Obama care he's been for a few
less taxes exactly because a lot and
Kamala Harris she's all of a sudden for
criminal justice reform she didn't
govern that way which is the Attorney
General of California and so as it gets
heated and let's be clear Biden is an
experienced politician he is not gonna
play fair with him he's got to go
they're every single thing that they did
and that's where you're gonna see that
experienced leader that's why I said
right now when it comes to the Democrats
he's the only candidate that has a shot
in the running because he has been that
consistent leader numbers tom from this
time in 2015 or 11 or 7 we would be
talking about a whole different group of
people yeah have to do with Trump that's
the thing even her 70 percent don't want
her to run they're mad at her because
she lost to Trump her numbers are so low
don't show your face around here again
yes and I think they will forgive every
day policy and none of it matters
anymore they will forgive bait oh
they'll intro I don't think if they
think he has the person there I don't
think they're right even the Bernie
Sanders people are not like solid Bernie
people right now right there are sort of
saying you're gonna have to court us a
little bit well to Morgans point it's a
good one there will be a debate in the
party about people saying look we just
need to win and someone like Joe Biden
or bado they can win versus this but we
need to win with a fill-in-the-blank
woman minority progressive whatever that
blank is and you're gonna have Democrats
who say job number one is to win and we
need to figure out how to do that and do
it care of the rest later you know it
was interesting to me and the poll that
we were all looking at earlier it
actually had 41% of Democrats thought
that Bernie should not run again and for
me when you see Bernie aim at Hillary
for me instead of instead of trying to
Tonya Harding you know baito
already in the process why isn't he
thank you I googled that to remember her
name earlier today but why don't why
doesn't Bernie sort of say you know what
I've set forth this more liberal agenda
for the party and I'm gonna help bring
up people like aoc and bade too and
others and bring up the next generation
but because it's not really about that
it's about he's selfish it's about power
more than it's about ideology they're
also power-hungry but they doesn't even
leave a movement and step aside and let
someone else I disagree in a way because
that new movement that is where the
energy is and so there was a time even
people on the right and I said this
yesterday on the five that we would
laugh at our Ocasio Cortes but they're
winning and it's not just her that's
winning there are incremental changes
that they want to make and I think the
the
Democrats have to take them seriously
they are the freedom caucus of the left
but they're only winning in certain
places and the way we took back the
majority in the house was by winning
moderate seats in Kansas City and
Savannah and Detroit and Denver all
these places we took back the house with
moderates a lot of the attention goes to
progressive do that's the fight you're
tonight's gonna be fun we gotta run guys
do you have any last thoughts Tom I mean
I agree it is gonna be fun we'll see
what happens we'll see that's my
favorite show